OK, so let's now get to this just crazy, dishonest
story from Kenosha, Wisconsin, where the term
crisis actor, which is often a staple of right
wing conspiracy theorists.
It almost works in this story. Take a listen
to this. So yesterday, Donald Trump went to
Kenosha, Wisconsin. The mayor didn't want
him there. The governor didn't want him there.
This was the site of unrest over the weekend,
last week, in fact. And this is the location
where 17 year old Kyle Rittenhouse was involved
in shooting multiple people, killing people
and ultimately charged with homicide. This
is the place. This is the epicenter.
And it turns out there was a business burned
down in Kenosha, which is a century old camera
shop, and it's owned by Tom Graham. Now, Tom
Graham, that's G.R. A.M., not JRA a H. A.M.
Just Tom Graham. G.R. a.m. Tom Graham was
invited to participate in a photo op with
Donald Trump in front of the burned down shop.
And he refused. He refused because he realized
he was going to be used as a political prop.
And he said, I'm not going to participate
in that. But if you watched the event, it
certainly seemed like the owner of that camera
shop was there.
And the reason is that they brought in a different
guy. They brought in the previous owner of
the camera shop. They got a stand in. They
got a guy to act in this crisis as if it has
hit it, as if it was his business that burned
down. If you look at the picture, you see
John Road now its road camera shop. So that
makes sense, right? Well, no, because John
Road hasn't been the owner of Road Camera
Shop for eight years. Check out this video
from the event.
So this was here one hundred and nine years,
just about the oldest in the nation doing
fantastic.
And we're going to help them a lot. I think
we're gonna help them a lot. Would you like
to this?
I just appreciate President Trump coming today.
Everybody here does. We're so thankful that
we got the federal troops in to help once
they got here. They did come down quite a
bit and our city up police and sheriff and
fire departments are awesome.
They work harder than you can believe 24/7.
This gentleman did a fantastic job working
with the federal government, and it was really
great. And once we said let's go. That was
the end of it. Unfortunately, that a few days
when people wouldn't call us, they didn't
want to have us come in. They just don't want
us to come in. And then disruption is done
a day early. We would have saved. You have
one day early on there.
Yeah, except it's not actually this guy's
store. The actual owner immediately refused
to participate, saying, quote, I think everything
he does, meaning Trump, I think everything
he does turns into a circus. And I just didn't
want to be involved in it. And he watched
on TV. Tom Graham saw on TV, Trump show up
and talk to the former owner and saw Jon Road
commend Donald Trump in his response to the
unrest in Kenosha and congratulate Trump for
sending in troops and all of this other stuff.
Is this a crisis actor? And I'm not really
saying it. I mean, OK, it's a term that right
wing conspiracy theorists love to use when
it doesn't apply. When we had the horrible,
horrible shooting, school shooting at Sandy
Hook in Connecticut. You add Alex Jones and
others talking about these are crisis actors.
There are no real victims, so on and so forth.
I think ultimately Alex Jones had to backtrack
on that because he got sued, but many others
were saying it as well. Crisis actors is a
phrase, a term that they love to use. That
actually seems to be a term that applies in
this particular case. And it has not been
this guy's store for eight years. And yet
he is presented as if it is his business that
has burned down. Now, TMJ for news reached
out to the White House to ask, why did Trump
claim that that was the business owner when
that is not the business owner and the business
owner, in fact, opted out of participating
here. They have not yet responded with a comment.
And I am sure that they either will not respond
or will come up with some justification as
opposed to saying we made a mistake. Why?
Because Donald Trump has never said that he
has made a mistake. And it is all in continuing
with the. So earlier in the show, I read a
quote from Aaron Roup Ha who I follow on Twitter,
and he posts a lot of great content. And Aaron
said, what exactly is the point of these visits
to places like Kenosha? The authorities don't
want the officials don't want Trump there.
He just shows up and meets with sycophants
and pretends that everybody is just so grateful
for him and then he leaves. That is the point.
And when you see this case where the actual
owner of the camera shop said, keep me the
hell out of it, and they get the guy who hasn't
owned it for eight years to stand there with
Trump, it is all optics. It doesn't the truth
doesn't matter from the point of view of the
image that Donald Trump is trying to create.
What matters is, can you find somebody to
praise me? That's what Trump cares about.
And that's exactly what
they did here.